consider the lilies of the field how
they grow they toil not neither do they
spin and yet I say unto you that even
Solomon in all his glory was not arrayed
like one of these wherefore if God so
clothes the grass of the field which
today is and tomorrow is cast into the
oven shall he not much more clothe you O
ye of little faith
therefore take no Thought saying what
shall we eat or what shall we drink or
wherewithal shall we be clothed those
are famous lines and that's sort of
Christ the hippie right it's like hey
let it all hang out
that's an old phrase do your thing and
everything will come to you and these
lines have been interpreted in that
manner many times but that's seriously
not the proper interpretation because
there's a kicker with this injunction
and the kicker is this for your heavenly
Father knows that you have need of all
these things but seek ye first the
kingdom of God and His righteousness and
all these things shall be added unto you
that's a lot different than the hippie
thing right because there's a very very
very interesting idea here it's it's
certainly one of the most profound ideas
that I've ever encountered and the idea
is this is that if you configure your
life so that what you are genuinely
doing is aiming at the highest possible
good then the things that you need to to
survive and to thrive on a day-to-day
basis will deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because it what
it basically says is if you dared to do
the most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else well how are you gonna find out if
that's true well it's a Kierkegaard
ian's leap of faith there's no way
you're gonna find out whether or not
that's true unless you do it so no one
no one can tell you either because just
because it works for someone else
I mean that's interesting and all that
but it's no proof that it'll work for
you you have to be all-in in this game
and so the idea is seek ye first the
kingdom of God and His righteousness
it's like that's actually a fairly
important caution when you're talking
about not having to pay attention to
what you're going to eat or what you're
going to wear it's like what it's
essentially saying is that those
problems are trivial in comparison and
the probability is that if you manifest
yourself properly in the world that
those things will come your way is
extraordinarily high and I believe I
believe that that's exactly right I mean
I I've watched people operate in the
world and I would say that there is no
more effective way of operating in the
world than to conceptualize the highest
good that you can and then strive to
attain it there's no more practical
pathway to the kind of success that you
could have if you actually knew what
success was and so that's what this
that's what this sermon is attempting to
to posit it's like in in the story of
Pinocchio you know what happens at the
beginning of the story of Pinocchio is
that Geppetto wishes on a star we talked
about that a little bit and so what
Geppetto does is align himself with the
metaphorical manifestation of the
highest good he can conceptualize and
say he says he makes a he makes a
commitment let's say he aims at the star
and for him the star is the possibility
that he can take his creation a puppet
right whose strings are being pulled by
unseen forces and have it transformed
into something that's autonomous and
real well that's a hell of an ambition
you know and we're wise enough to put
that into children's movie but too
foolish to understand what it means it's
such an interesting juxtaposition that
that we can both know that and not know
it at the same time you can go to the
movie you can watch it and it makes
sense but that doesn't mean that you can
go home and think well I know what that
meant
well people are complicated right we
exist at different levels and all the
levels don't communicate
with one another but but the movie is a
hypothesis and the hypothesis is there's
no better pathway to self-realization
and the in noblemen of being than to
pause it the highest good that you can
conceive of and commit yourself to it
and then you might also ask yourself and
this is definitely worth asking is do
you really have anything better to do
and if you don't well why would you do
anything else therefore take no thought
for the morrow for the moral shall take
thought for the things of itself
sufficient unto the day is the evil
thereof I spend a long time trying to
figure out without man to because it's
another one of those lines that can
easily be read as programmer and Aunty
ant you know you remember the old fable
of the grasshopper in the end maybe not
I'm not gonna tell it but the ant works
in the grasshopper fiddles and the ant
has a pretty good time in the winter and
the grasshopper dies and so this is like
a pro grasshopper line but it's not
because it says something else it says
that if you orient yourself properly and
then pay attention to what you do every
day that works and I actually think that
that's in accordance with what we have
come to understand about human
perception because what happens is that
the world shifts itself around your aim
does you're a creature that has a name
you have to have a name in order to do
something you're an aiming creature you
look at a point and you move towards it
it's built right into you and so you
have an aim well let's say your aim is
the highest possible aim well then so
that sets up the world around you it
organizes all of your perceptions it
organizes what you see and you don't see
it organizes your emotions and your
motivations so you organize yourself
around that aim and then what happens is
the day manifests itself as a set of
challenges and problems and if you solve
them properly then you stay on the
pathway towards that ape and you can
concentrate on the on the eight on the
day and so that way you get to have your
cake and eat it too because you can you
can point into the distance the far
distance
and you can live in the day and it seems
to me that that's that makes every
moment of the day super charged with
meaning that that's how because if
everything that you're doing every day
is related to the highest possible aim
that you can conceptualize well that's
the very definition of the meaning that
would sustain you in your life well and
then the issue is well back to Noah well
all hell is about to break loose and
chaos is coming it's like when that's
happening in your life you might want to
be doing something that you regard is
truly worthwhile because that's what
will keep you afloat when when
everything is flooded and you don't want
to wait until the flood comes to start
doing that because if your arks half
built and you don't know how to captain
it the probability is very high that
that you'll drown